this episode is sponsored by endl an app
that creates personalized soundscapes to
help you focus relax and sleep
the first 100 people to click our link
in the description will get a one week
free trial
[Music]
[Music]
depending on your love of horror stories
or your belief in the supernatural it
might be easy to convince you that lakes
are full of ghosts
that as you plunge deeper into these
lakes depths you will come across
translucent bodies that come alive when
nighttime sets in
what you might not expect however is
that the ghosts look like this
an elongated body with its limbs all
packed close to the head wrenching open
and closed like scissors that propel our
spectral friend in jarring motions this
is leptodora a genus of water flea whose
transparent bodies have inspired many of
the researchers who study them to call
them
ghost fleas
leptodora are cladocerins the more
scientific name given to water fleas and
clodosarins are microsized members of
the crustacean family making the ghost
flea a distant approximately centimeter
length relative of the much less spooky
lobsters and shrimp
the leptodora is more closely related to
daphnia a creature who we've come across
before on our journey through the
microcosmos and for daphnia the
leptadora family relation is kind of an
unfortunate one because frankly
leptadora don't care about it they have
more important things to focus on like
for example eating daphnia so if you're
trying to hunt down the ghost flea the
key is to look for lakes that are full
of plankton eating fish because those
lakes tend to be full of planktonic
clodosarens like daphnia for james our
master of microscopes there is a
specific lake in warsaw that seems to
meet the criteria and that has reliably
turned up leptodora
but even when he is able to track them
down and watch them under the microscope
it can be difficult for him to maintain
them in his own home they seem to be
particularly sensitive to the conditions
of the water they live in but
unfortunately we don't know exactly what
it is that they are sensitive to
so we're lucky to be able to see the
ones that we can
now despite its transparent body there
is one feature of the leptodora that
clearly stands out the single cyclops
eye that wobbles at the front end of the
flea attached to a tube that extends
into the leptadora's body
when you zoom in you can see slices that
look like thin petals projecting out
from the center of the eye there are
around 500 of these slices and they are
each a crystalline cone structure called
an amitidium
within each ametidium are five cells
that help the leptadora see
but just as important is what the
omnitime doesn't have
the edges are lacking pigments which
helps the leptadora stay more
transparent to avoid detection by
predators
this eye helps the leptadora move in
response to the light around it and it
may even help the flea find areas with
food but interestingly when a group of
researchers studied the leptodora's
hunting habits in 1989 they found that
sometimes the luptodora would be
swimming and swimming in search of food
only to swim right past a perfectly good
meal as if they couldn't see it and
other times they described the leptadora
attacking random bits of debris or empty
cladosser and carapaces again as if they
could not see what they were targeting
and what that suggested to the
researchers is that perhaps the ghost
flea doesn't use its eye to hunt
instead it seems to be a primarily
tactile hunter using its own body like a
bear trap that springs into action upon
the slightest touch
the leptador's thoracic legs surround
its mouth creating a sort of trap or
basket for its food and in fact this
structure has names like feeding basket
or trap basket to describe its purpose
so very precisely
leptodora spend the daytime at the
bottom of their lakes hiding out in the
low oxygen areas that keep them safe
from fish that want to eat them and
during the night time the leptodora will
rise to the surface deploying its trap
basket body in the process
as it swims through the waters and prey
brushes up against them the leptador's
body responds on instinct pulling its
abdomen forward and grabbing its legs
around its new meal like a very very
dangerous hug
and from there the leptadora uses its
mandibles to dig the tissue out of its
prey and consume it disposing of the
unwanted bits of carapace that surround
their meal the way that we might discard
a shrimp tail
in some instances researchers have also
observed male leptodora using their
longer antennae which are much shorter
in females to sweep food into their
feeding basket this is both a practical
use of antenna and a very interesting
observation because for most of the year
male leptodora don't actually
exist
you could say that they are the most
ghostly ghost flea of all
[Music]
for most of the year leptodora
reproduced parthenogenetically which
means that they simply lay their eggs
without relying on any other
fertilization the female leptador's
brood chamber fills with yellowish eggs
that are produced asexually and
eventually those eggs will hatch into
larvae inside the leptadora and for most
of the year those hatched leptodora will
be female
but in the fall
male leptadora begin to appear
their main function is to allow for
sexual reproduction which gives the
ghost flea a chance to mix its genes and
produce a more diverse population and
the eggs that result from sexual
reproduction are different from the
parthogenetic eggs instead of being kept
in the leptadora herself these
transparent eggs called resting eggs are
released into the water where they will
eventually sink to the bottom of the
lake
and the eggs remain until one day they
hatch
a new ghost to haunt its lake
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you to endl
for sponsoring this episode endl is an
app that takes everything we know about
sound combines it with technology and
creates personalized soundscapes to help
you focus relax and sleep their app was
named the apple watch app of the year in
2020 and they have a brand new
soundscape called wind down that they
made in collaboration with james blake
the goal of wind down is to help you
transition from an active day to a
calmer state so it is great just before
bed too
sound has a direct impact on your
physical and mental well-being and by
adapting in real time to things like
your location weather and heart rate
endl creates simple pleasant sounds that
can help to calm your mind if you're
interested in trying out endl just be
one of the first hundred people to
download it using the link in our
description and you will get a free week
of audio experiences
the folks whose names are on the screen
right now they are our patreon patrons
without whom we definitely and
completely could not make this lovely
little youtube show
that hopefully you enjoy so if you want
to be thankful that cool things get to
exist join me and being thankful to them
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss you can check
out jam and germs on instagram and if
you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you